Oh my man,
Duncan Trussell has been here for the podcast.
I believe this maybe the fifth or six times.
I think you've been on more than anybody else and said you're the greatest guy
ever.
Crt is nobody better than you for the podcast.
You're the most entertaining.
Interesting.
And you're changing the world,
dude.
Whether they liked it or not.
You're freaking p two fists and flashlights.
It's got two.
He's got one that he could pretend as a beer can.
It's kind of sneaky ass asshole.
That's better.
I theoretically at the front and the back,
maybe a mouth feel.
Oh,
it says like girls.
I think it's a model that there some particularly fun stuff.
Let's see.
Oh my God.
It's modeled after Margaret Thatcher.
Pour it out.
Imagine Margaret Thatcher was into,
this is modeled after someone named Teagan.
It comes with Lou and I guess it's modeled after her.
He put apparently plays guitar.
She's pictured here with the electric guitar.
What is that,
sir?
How did they do that?
Is that a little cliches or a muscle car behind her to Mustang perhaps your
break Christmas.
You know what?
Holding the flashlight.
I could say anything.
I get like come up with like cure for all disease.
You know the,
you're in the perfect position as a comic where if you were sending girls
pictures of your Dick,
it wouldn't hurt your career at all.
You would go on stage and say,
look guys,
here's the deal.
Okay.
I,
yes,
what I did was stupid,
but I get lonely and I'm in front of my computer and I do dumb shit.
I'm not a bad person or hurting anybody.
Yeah.
Never even fucked anybody.
He never even fucked anybody who wiener.
Please don't.
We did.
Sherry didn't catch him fucking end game and catch him,
but he definitely did well in this little thing.
What got him fired?
None of it had to do with him fucking somebody.
He definitely,
someone's skeptical.
I'm skeptical that he did that.
He just sent pictures of his direct cock and underwear and nothing else.
It's the end.
Everybody's got their thing.
Did we ever dated a girl?
Doesn't anyone have sex?
Just wants to blow you now.
Now you've never dated a girl who only wants to give blowjobs.
I would hate that girl.
I know a few friends that have had that girl.
Yeah,
I know.
I have one friend who's like,
you shouldn't even know like sex.
She just likes to blow me and then
she have a penis.
Maybe no sex before.
She just doesn't like it.
Maybe it's because or posts you sort of eaten up awards.
Charles,
I've cut that out.
Love you and we don't want to think bad has happened to you.
Yes,
that's right.
Thank you.
Bye Bye.
Ooh.
Oh,
Brian Cowen was on the podcast today.
Ladies and gentlemen,
almost always the grands.
Podcasts of all time when the Brian Cowen,
Duncan Trussell,
Joe Diaz podcast,
that's the,
that's the deadly.
That's the
TRIFECTA.
Trifecta.
We call it the TRIFECTA.
The axis of evil.
That's the best I think everybody should do.
Contobox is just doing a little bit of actual really good.
I feel like a fucking man.
Right?
I feel like I just had coffee or something.
Yeah.
I'm getting sick.
My neck.
I'm intimidated.
If you are intimidating guy,
what am I neck?
Scary.
Frightening to be this close in proximity to a killer.
I like.
That's all I do.
The guys I know who are pro fighters,
I just,
I can't help it.
It's just an idiot.
But just like when you answer,
say if I'm here and I'm like this and then I go,
hey,
like that,
what do you do?
I'll ask the question.
Nothing.
You fucking crumpling you learn,
want to learn how to fly or quite with a bolster your key other than that.
Yeah.
Other than that,
uh,
it,
it doesn't really work.
And if it did,
people would be training in Kung Fu when they stepped into the after guy.
A lot of guys go well,
but in real life,
if I'm hearing,
you know,
the funniest thing is when people say,
well,
hey bro,
you know what you do as a sport,
as a sports situation,
the best stuff works on trained killers and the trained killers are the guys
like mayhem did Martha Vega,
there is one guy I know who,
who uh,
I think his name's Mark Makita and he,
uh,
he took a,
he's a knife fighter.
Like Katie teaches knife fighting like on a high level and he goes,
he goes up.
He was talking about is an important learning Jujitsu.
Absolutely.
Do you need to understand ground funding?
Do you see what I'm saying?
Kicking and punching.
Yes,
and he knows it all.
He goes,
he goes,
but you know,
I got out,
he pulled out a little,
he was like this and it was a little hook thing like that.
And he goes,
see now this,
I can actually scribe your spine from the front,
from the front.
And he goes,
see this year about eight inches,
you're in shape.
He goes,
see this?
I get in here and I'm,
I basically am bumping against your spine and I pull here.
Then he goes this to me,
he goes,
see now we're in a fight here and you,
you throw a punch or whatever.
I catch you here.
What's hide?
I'm like,
that.
See,
like all you stabbing goes skivvy now I take my knife and I cut all this soft
seat and I go,
oh.
And then he goes,
God,
I keep cutting and he's doing this with this rubber knife.
And I was like,
that's what I was doing.
You see that face?
I was going,
hello?
Like this game.
This is terribly goes.
Yeah,
that's real fighting this way.
He told me,
he said,
he's got this little hook thing and he goes like this.
He goes,
see if I'm standing here like that and you don't see you just,
you'd,
it looks like a,
I'm just holding things.
It looks like a,
like a key holder.
But if I come under here and pull this,
then your whole life,
someone screaming.
Yeah,
that's weird.
Stop filming.
Turns out those kids screaming was just kids playing,
which is always good.
It's always good to be wrong.
Brian Killen was awesome on the podcast and uh,
since we didn't really end to end his interview,
we'll do it this way.
Powerful Thomas girl,
ladies and gentleman,
he's here
next week.
I start back on fear factor again.
Holy Shit.
That's ridiculous.
I can't even believe I agreed to do that.
I'm like a goddamn raccoon young,
something shining in front of my face.
And I said,
yes,
it's shiny.
It's going to be eating.
[inaudible].
I'm Joe Rogan and this is fear factor and the stunts are about to see where all
design that supervised by trained professionals.
They are extremely dangerous and should not be attempted by anyone anywhere.
Anytime I remembered that and then under any circumstances don't add shit
to me.
[inaudible] I said [inaudible] want anywhere,
anytime.
That is any circumstances you critique is like
what about this shit?
And then I have to say evidently fear is not a factor for you.
Everything else is free ball.
You're going to get that back now people are going to come and say that to you
again.
Now
again,
I've gone back to my post fear factor days where everyone would get,
you know,
my boy wants needs more and that's like your how many times have you heard
people say that?
No,
it's the [inaudible] as well.
It's going to make comedy a little more interesting.
It's going to be old heckles that are new again,
right?
Because it's
already got that shit right.
I'm already,
I'm already ready.
I'm ready.
Ready?
I don't.
I hope not,
but it probably will,
but I think it will survive.
The good thing about the podcast is the podcast fans buy out the tickets before
the retards have a shot at it.
Right,
so that's what it's going to keep them out of.
Clues.
Steps on stirrup.
We'll see you guys soon and soon.
There's a lot of shit going on.
Ah,
shit man.
A lot of shit happen.
Tommy Segura is going to go to Montreal and we'll get a full fold.
The description of what happened there when he comes back on his podcast,
which is your mom's house,
your mom's House on desk squad and that TV.
You could find that shit on iTunes.
This might be the most boring fucking post podcasts interview we've ever done.
This no fucking continuity to any of the things we're saying where there's no
energy behind it when I have a lot to offer you today,
but look,
there's cycles good and bad.
There's pro and con.
There's ebbs and flows.
The wave it comes in,
it goes out.
Can I,
oh,
this is the wrap up of the podcast.
We had a very fascinating podcast with Giorgio from ancient aliens and of course
a good time as your bra.
Who is it to just satisfy your,
uh,
your,
your anxious knowledge alien thing?
Alex Jones.
I just want them to talk
when I told him that you were coming on the podcast man site too,
I got to do this podcast with you.
I've got,
I've got to see this guy.
I got the questions for this guy,
but Nazis and aliens.
A lot of questions.
That was a good time is the first podcast here we gun.
Are you going to what?
Let's just do this like this.
Yes.
But I've done a lot of over the phone
tweet that I'll read to it.
You've done a lot over the phone.
Yeah.
This is definitely more interesting picture of US intimately,
right?
Yeah.
So this is the first time I've ever done a podcast like this.
We'd get to go deep,
deep,
deep into the crazy Ben.
Cause he,
I told you,
you broke my crazy meter with the ark of the Covenant Day.
I love it.
It's never happened before.
I think that like,
listen,
the fuck is he saying?
He's saying it was a fucking vending machine.
Yes.
An extraterrestrial one.
None of us.
It's pretty crazy stuff,
man.
What is it like living in your world is overwhelmed by all this speculation and
crazy stuff and things that most people will never take seriously,
but yet you're,
you've spent on incredible amount of time invested in all these things.
What does that like man?
Well,
I mean,
look,
I,
uh,
it's,
it's bizarre.
I mean,
I rarely,
I rarely go to conferences because,
because there's so much weird stuff going on as it's even weird for me,
you know?
And,
and that's,
and that's the thing that,
you know,
I'm just some dude,
I'm just a regular guy and the moment I hear about,
you know,
crazy,
crazy stuff to me,
it's like,
you know,
slow it down a second here because this is,
how are you going to lose the mainstream?
Because just to talk about the potential or the possibility at ets,
where here,
dude,
that's fucking enough.
That's enough.
You know and so,
so need vending machines for space.
What about [inaudible] possible?
You can't even put a dollar billing between the fittings
about it.
Freddy Loc hard and I was just talking about keeping the pimp hand strong.
He was just telling me how it keeps a pimp hand strong and I got admitted some
high level shit.
He knows what the fuck he's doing done.
It's done.
It's a man who's grown up with it.
Did,
did your dad have a strong compound?
Extremely.
It's still strong.
It works on me still.
Yeah.
So you could tell him,
man,
you understand the psychology behind the pimp hand strong.
You need to let you know.
If you don't use the pen pen then things get out of control and you can take an
advantage of the dazzling.
You're right.
You got to realize that nature in this life.
And women want men and men want women and occasionally a woman wants to be a man
and a man wants to be a woman and that's a catastrophe.
And what a woman wants to be a man and you're a man you usually submit because
she has the pussy and then you know what I'm in anymore.
She's the math.
When someone's telling you what to do with that person to the your man,
at least how your man a little pussy and some companionship,
the only sound,
anything that's your happiness,
not your man that don't rely on anybody for anything ever.
That's how public service messages of the day.
Now that I'm back on NBC,
the whole,
you know,
keeps a pimp hand strong the more you know like rainbows and shit.
My pants ready.
Lockhart Lockhart has a brand new podcast folks.
For those of you who are watching this video blog,
we don't actually listen to the podcast cause you ain't got that kind of time.
I understand that you're out there a Fetty Lockhart has a fantastic podcast
though.
If you ever,
I'm going to go on a trip.
You know what I'm saying?
I want to go somewhere.
Your needs.
Listen to something.
Your 11 hours on a plane Friday.
Lockhart's podcasts.
Perfect for such situations.
Yeah,
it's called what's good.
It's on the death squad label can get on iTunes for free.
It's free.
If you don't like it,
you don't have to listen,
then tune in next week.
You know,
I thought I would delete that too.
He's a fuck.
I hope you'll,
I think you'll like it.
I hope so.
There's those who do and those who haven't heard,
you know,
you don't even do guests yet.
Right now you're just like interacting with people on Twitter and shit on
finding it.
We're finding the voice and then I think I might start playing my own guests.
Maybe dude,
go back.
When we were doing our first podcast,
Brian and I started over a year ago,
year and a half ago.
It was terrible.
We were awful.
The first couple of podcasts are unwatchable snowflakes and we'll like reading
off Twitter.
What is he saying?
What is wrong with this guy?
We're like,
it was like so dumb and boring.
Yeah.
He let me know the first,
the second one,
cause I snuck in and Twitter.
So much as if you're listening to this on your iPod a couple of days later,
this is not exciting.
So I was like,
yeah,
all right,
I'll leave to,
you know,
you've got to leave.
I think the third time we just did it more relaxed.
The second time it was almost like it's a radio show going to be professional.
But then the third time it's like,
yeah,
just shoot the shit and see where we had one mistake that we did where we let
people in the chat room,
we let a chat room rather than we like read the chat room and it's also like
nigger,
nigger kind craziness.
Fuck you fucking,
we'd have to ban this guy and this guy would be spam and show me your cock.
Oh are so crazy.
They just,
they just want you to acknowledge them.
They want their name to be said.
Yes.
So we had to figure it out.
We had to figure out that you can't talk to them and you're just going to kind
of do your own thing and you got to listen to feedback.
You learn from some feedback,
but you gotta you know,
you also got to like insulate some people for having an impact on the show.
Nah,
there's no part of it.
That's the only God damn crazy.
It's so fascinating.
There's so many nutty fucking people out there.
And uh,
when you have a podcast,
you could bring those nutty people together.
Yeah.
The death squad label,
I ran into a guy in San Diego of his lesson.
He was telling me everything about it.
Should I forgot about this?
The first one we did.
Oh Man.
People love it,
man.
It helps them get through their day.
Know if you have a boring ass job,
some shit during the day while you're doing things.
Yes,
but it's making radio passe now isn't that a buddy of mine emailed me,
said he went to a bar,
we went to a bar.
I think that there's somewhere in the north east.
Went to a bar and in the inside the barn,
they were playing the podcast.
Oh Wow.
Speakers.
Why was it the ice house two weeks ago,
the bartender,
I went to go pay.
He goes,
I listened to on Joe Rogan's podcast.
They charge charging your nothing's Freddy Loc
that strong ladies and gentlemen.
I mean,
boom.
Hey,
we're back with my friend,
formerly known as Chris now,
Aubrey,
what's going on?
It's so fucked up on Iowasca.
He changed his name and you can see the whole story or listened to it or
whatever you want to do.
A podcast one,
one 27,
27.
Yeah,
whatever.
If you read about it,
I'm warrior poet,
a u s there you go read about it and you can watch his videos on it and uh,
it's not for kids.
This is some real shit folks right out.
We just got started doing the podcast and uh,
I think what I told him was that I think it was the best depiction of the
Iowasca experience that I had ever heard.
The most detailed,
the most compelling,
the best story.
It was really,
you went in depth and you,
you did it without any worry about how ridiculous the sounds.
He didn't apologize for any of it.
You just,
you just jumped in there.
It's easy when you're just telling what happened.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like I didn't have to.
It is,
but it's not,
yeah.
Well,
maybe not how you do it,
but it's so,
I mean,
I didn't have to make anything up.
That's what happened to me out there.
So it sounds like complete utter horse shit.
But yeah,
for sure.
It's just because it's too crazy for our reality.
It's too crazy for our reality.
But that was the beauty of the way you told it is that even though it sounds
like complete other wish it like on paper,
you know you're reading it,
you go what?
But the way you said it was so sincere and so,
so honest and open about it.
Like you know,
just like this is what happened.
This is what I saw.
That's what I felt is what I experienced.
No apologies goes a very fascinating man.
I guarantee you it's a lot of people listen to that and they're going to go and
try that shit.
I should up,
bro.
It can only benefit your life.
I mean if you go,
you know,
maybe I'll write a blog or something.
There's some basic things you learned.
Don't fight it.
You know,
don't try to fucking,
you know,
let things happen.
Let the medicine work and follow some basic guidelines and it'll change your
life for the better.
And the guy you went with that they called the Dragon,
the Dragon.
The Maestro.
Maestro.
Orlando's cure on Dama.
Yeah.
Do we need to get that dude on Twitter?
Oh yeah.
I watch him up.
You know,
he's got just to give you his number.
Learning.
Yeah.
Text him in touch with them by email.
But you've got to learn Spanish cause it's a bit of an option.
All right.
Did the Rosetta stone get all that shit son on it?
Alright,
we got to go to a movie premiere.
We're going to go see Kevin Smith's red state.
Hopefully it's good.
Yeah,
I'm excited.
I love cat in a blaze up and see what the fuck is up.
But thank you for tuning into the podcast and the podcast video blog and we'll
see you soon.
Okay,
bye.
Bye.
[inaudible]
and um,
they're celebrities.
Cause I don't know if you know this is America,
but are there actually the guys who brought planking to America fucking serious?
Yes.
So,
uh,
please welcome the very talented Walsh brothers.
Hm.